you got cooking let me spit out birds
waiting to get filled with mom eat yeah
right Carl Oh in this package would ever
let Carl get up in them I'm gonna put
your [ __ ] hand down you're ruining my
joke ketchup no mustard Oh sausages and
buns because we belong together
I know it's against the rules but just
the tips prepare yourself little sausage
you're about to learn the terrible truth
cooking something Oh beautiful matter
it's just beautiful as soon as you're
out those doors [ __ ] the gods kill our
asses you [ __ ] [ __ ] nice
peace and all over gotta be
that doesn't make any sense why would
they do that huh because it makes them
stronger
hungers insatiable buddy I mean [ __ ] how
do you know all this
Rita non-perishable [ __ ] I gotta
tell everyone he will die otherwise
thank you meanie what the cuts are doing
this to us because we touched him I mean
it was fine it's not like anyone writes
home and says oh god I had the best tip
together we can fight these monsters and
take control of our own lives come on
join the fight
make it rain
Oh Gary just throw this [ __ ]
toothpick at me man
we need to make them see us I have a
plan here goes everything
wah hello alive and looking at me with
your little shoes and your arms and your
legs look at me ain't got no legs you
think I got them leg wanted it her to
you you don't wanna [ __ ] know
yes we're chosen hey Brenda
you and me